Sara's with us in Chicago
hi Sara welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi it's so good to talk to you you too
what's up so I'll try to make this brief
it's complicated but anyways my husband
is a helicopter pilot he has a very
lucrative career he's done very well he
worked really really hard completed the
entire program in the nine months his
parents funded that seven years ago his
cousin on his mom's side decided that
they wanted to be a helicopter pilot too
there was no money so his mom convinced
the grandparents to loan her a hundred
thousand dollars to do it
she was given a hundred thousand dollars
didn't follow the program broke every
rule that was set my husband my
father-in-law was against it it was kind
of it was kind of a joke in the family
it's my husband myself and my
father-in-law against his mom and her
mom there was no accountability she
would go on trips and spent I mean you
name it she did it this is your mother
or your mother-in-law's sister
my mother-in-law it's my mother the
girls wanting to fly is my
mother-in-law's niece
yeah but who screwed up the money your
mother-in-law my mother-in-law and her
mom okay misbehave didn't blew the money
is that what you're saying yeah pretty
much
so anyways to fast forward now my
husband and I bought our own personal
helicopter two years ago and now my
mother-in-law wants us to let this
cousin use it to keep I call it funding
from this behavior they call it
showing grace and that the problem is me
I just don't like her and my husband and
I made it this is where it gets icy so
my husband and I made the decision when
we bought the helicopter that she was
not going to use it and that was our
decision however now my father-in-law
has given up on trying to defend this
it's been a whole marriage problem with
them so he's taken my mother-in-law side
so my father-in-law calls that my
husband and on those the decisions that
we made so now you know it doesn't your
husband did your husband wimped your
father wanted another power to do that
only your husband does
okay well my husband says that you and
your husband need to see a marriage
counselor because his parents are freaks
that's what you've just described to me
and if the two of you don't get on the
same page on how to deal with the Freak
Show that is his family you're going to
end up divorced okay does that make
sense to you
his family's a freak show and you can't
fix them and you can't even do they'll
be the one that sets the boundaries he
has to set the boundaries because that's
what he's suggesting he says well you
march in there and you said no he needs
time he needs to actually he needs to
actually have a backbone run down the
Walmart on all three pick up a backbone
boy
your mama's crazier than a bean and your
wife is right you need to keep your word
to your life how okay so this how would
you answer this I get asked all the time
well how do you know your rules are
right I don't even know how to defend
that because it's my freakin helicopter
I don't have to defend my rules it's my
house it's my I want to drive your car
no well how do you know that's okay
because it's my car and I decide
no it's not it doesn't it's not mean
it's it's saying look we have decided
that this is how we're gonna run our
lives and if you don't like that then
you have to decide how you're going to
react to that but we can't we can't
control your reaction all we can control
is what we are going to do and here's
what we're going to do we don't loan out
our helicopter by the way to anybody
anybody we don't give it a team by l-c
they're non family members if somebody
else walks up to and says oh i want to
use your no we don't helicopter is not
something you you know you loan it to
somebody over the weekend hello even my
husband has even said things like to me
if this causes my parents get divorced
I'll never forgive you
then you need marriage counseling your
husband is more loyal to his parents
than he is to his wife by the way he set
up a game he set up a boundary he's the
one that went back on his word how about
I don't forgive you for you know having
no backbone when your father called I
think you're I think you're hitting on a
major column because his dad will openly
it must be a generational thing because
his dad will openly admit that he loves
his son more than he loves his wife well
there you go so I feel like for richer
for poorer in sickness into health you
leave your parents and cleave to your
spouse I love my parents my mother my
wife well of my wife's parents they do
not run my house my daughters aren't my
son are married I do not run their house
they run their house I have to respect
their decisions they're grown people
they have their thing my son just got
married in April and you know his new
wife is not going to have to struggle
with the Ramseys
getting between the two of them if they
if one of the Ramseys does that they'll
have to deal with me because that's not
gonna happen
I mean can one last quote I mean yeah I
guess you're it's all bulls don't his
I've been told by the entire family if I
don't do what his mom says she'll hate
me for the rest of my life oh well oh
well I have to I have to put up with a
bully I have to do everything you say
and that's the only way you like me no
that's that's not liking you that means
you're a wuss and you have no opinion
and no backbone you're a jellyfish and
you know you're not even a real adult
you just this woman pushes everybody
around this this chick is she's a test
pilot for a broom Factory I mean what
you're describing here is completely
dysfunctional family I'm not a financial
can an shal counselor I'm not a family
counselor but I'm running this crap all
the time around the money issues the
book is boundaries by dr. Henry cloud
you and your husband need to get that
and you need to read it by Monday and
you need to be in marriage counseling
sometime in the next four days this is
not going to end well Sara if you guys
don't take a proactive stance to protect
your marriage this is not a
mother-in-law problem it's not a
helicopter problem it's not a nice
problem and it's not a grandmother
problem it's a marriage problem am I
wrong I think you pretty much hit it on
the head yeah
if the here's the thing when you set
boundaries with people like his mother
the first thing they do is attack those
boundaries because they don't like
boundaries they think and they're gonna
be angry boundary lists people don't
like being told where the fences are the
first thing you did first thing you did
you set a boundary on the helicopter
what they do they all immediately went
after that boundary and you're not crazy
they are there it's a classic case study
its classic in this space book is
boundaries by dr. Henry cloud it'll be
the new Bible for your house one of them
anyway
and you guys are going to sit down and
gets you to not be on the same page
about the crazy his crazy family because
they're they're consuming you guys and
they're going to consume this marriage